the next talk will be valid OB yeah so
thanks and thanks also to enjoy it about
for this great exposition because then I
can like zoom through the first few
slides and let me say that this is a
joint work with the Ameer Abdullah Alex
and Dhoni and Robbie come on who I've
seen maybe here oh yeah over there you
had good questions and asked me doing it
talks like difficult question then you
should ask hobby yeah thanks and this is
like somewhat older paper right in the
current I don't know Twitter kind of
like 2014 but I just put it here just to
in case you can look for this walk or
something for details ok so I'm talking
about the same problem near neighbours
question I'm gonna use not repeat the
definition use P for the set of points
of the data and for the number of points
and D which was in San Choi stock was P
little P like fourfold a dimension Oh
actually it's going to be like the
ambient dimension and still Q is stands
for query okay and you want to find like
the closest point which you're gonna
usually denote by P star among all the
points little P P star is the optimal
point okay so let me skip this that
we're gonna talk about in general there
could be different distances but I'm
going to talk about Euclidean spaces
okay so it's known that there is
generally curse of dimensionality this
is like a different problem is
Sanjoy mentioned so really the issue is
that this large dimension D in silly
like particular when it's the T ambient
dimension you may hope that some of the
dimension is D but some of the data is
more structure it's not worst case of
adversarial configuration anyone a
leverage that information alright so
this is the definition of C approximate
nearest neighbor search right the same
see that enjoy head then you want to
find any point which I'm gonna use P
prime which is almost as good as the
optimal point pistol
okay good so usually in the enables such
algorithms I'm going to talk about the
algorithmic
effect of like designed fast or good
algorithms so most algorithms actually
talk about space partitions one way or
another so in low dimension level of
walk and it's like partial list of
results and very different innocence
space partitions are used in low
dimensions and in high dimensions for
example in low dimensional one of the
most frequent things like this KD trees
that Sanjay mentioned in high dimensions
usually LSH right so that's roughly
speaking the references
alright so and KD this is the KD tree
that is how you split the space when you
we process the point and this is how you
execute the query when you have the
query you basically search anything
among these partitions so it's kind of
like a base going through a binary tail
traversing one path in a binary tree
okay so we're gonna talk about high
dimensional spaces and a very useful
tool here is the dimensionality
reduction or the Johnson engine starts
lemma which says that you can project
reduce the dimension significantly and
it's been used somewhat similarly to
this KD trees okay so now what I want to
talk to about today is really these like
just the background I want to talk about
some data I will partition so some as
opposed to this Johnson image so just
projects in a random direction in high
dimensional cases there are some walks
that actually look at the data points
that you have then choose the direction
to project not uniformly from the sphere
which was also mentioned means enjoys
talk about this split not spill trees
the split trees so the direction there
was was uniformly from the units feel
yeah in many many we'll talk about this
where the direction is chosen not
uniformly but actually using the data
the data points that you have to bias
the day the directions okay and in
general you wanna say maybe maybe this
can optimize improve the result because
now it's optimized to to the input data
okay so maybe if the points lie on kind
of something
look like lying on a lawn generally like
this line this direction there may be
directly when a project is not just
random from this field but along this
direction or something very close to it
and it will give you the most
information okay then you after you do
that maybe you repeat on each subset of
the point in some way like for example
here if you after we project the points
on this go back to a particularly first
line then you split right the left like
in KD trees that enjoy mention and I
sleep in my slides you have 50% of the
point zero fifty percent of the points
here then you do it recursively on each
one a similar computation okay then it
will be somewhat similar I'll go with
him now the questions how to choose this
direction by the mentioned that there
are what I described before was really
using the signal in the data using
conflict the most significant direction
which is basically like the direction
determined by SVD of PCA
you can pick your favorite acronym here
so there's been a lot of work on this
and these are like some partial list of
references and how to do this right you
choose this direction that I said in the
beginning using PC iOS VD and then you
speed the points maybe into two or maybe
you've optimized somewhat differently
but then you do a cursory on each they
have the points but they so it's
somewhat similar to KD trees except that
the split is not according today like
the original character is according to
the standard basis the big tree is
according to a random direction and here
it's according to say the top direction
from the PCA back to okay now its data a
well because the direction depends on
the data so the entire data structure
depends highly on I mean is optimized
for the data okay now in practice it all
these papers that are like more
empirical they show very good
performance and they claim to outperform
say LSH or these kind of methods which
are known to have be like almost optimal
theoretically on the other hand there's
no proof that this method works like
this like empirically they're very
successful they give a lot of in a lot
of
high accuracy using fast running times
more storage and kind things so people
usually use them anyone understand why
okay me now we know that Junction
initiatives result on this dimension
reduction optimal okay so is there like
a way to understand this non worst case
scenario may be so I'm going to suggest
a specific model and then talk about two
algorithms are different but somehow
follow the same outline that I mentioned
here with this PC using the PCIe
directions and we were able to analyze
both of them mathematically to say give
accuracy guarantees because they are the
specific mode and I'm going to tell you
about okay so what is the model is like
a probabilistic method or model or maybe
half or ballistic have worst case so in
general I'm gonna have like a low
dimensional signal with a large noise
okay so it's sitting in a very high
dimensional space but let's support the
sea-bottom color here the signal is that
is some subspace so all the points come
off is from a subspace u the U stands
for hidden Oh
unknown okay so there's a sub unknown
subspace which is low dimensional okay
dimension K which is much smaller than D
okay so this hidden subspace think just
take it think of it like like a three
dimensional subspace or maybe two
dimensional subsidy maybe even one
dimensional subspace is a huge high
dimensional space and all your points
come from this hidden subspace okay so
in a sense you think you're walking with
a low dimensional problem but just don't
see it of course if you're giving the
point in this way you are able to see it
but in a second you won't but yeah
right right this is let me on subspace
but you don't see that in your subspace
okay it's like yeah and then your actual
data so it's like the the signal the to
signal but it's perturbed by by some
noise so the data is really each point
in this subspace is perturbed by a full
dimensional Gaussian noise so the
patient takes it out of this subspace
okay no is really large as you're going
to see in a minute okay so this is
really difficult to identify the
subspace okay so this is like a one
dimensional case the points are supposed
to be exactly on this thing and now you
move them away and it's a huge noise so
kind of like they look like all around
okay okay so to formulate a little bit
I'm going to take the matrix P so I
don't remember maybe the columns or the
data points and just add iid gaussians
like she doesn't matter with the columns
of the bulbs and you get a new mattress
feed tilde okay and so P is the
unperturbed P tilde is a tube data and
what you see in the algorithm is only
that were to break the perturbed attic
of course I'm gonna assume that each
point is at least unit norm so the
signal has there is a signal it's not
going to zero that's kind of a can a
normalization gonna see it for every
point and I'll get a query point I'm
going to choose the query point in a
specific way right like very close to
one of the points okay so it's like I
can strike there is the correct answer
that you want to answer that is you're
supposed to answer so the rule is not
arbitrary it's very close to one of the
points or relatively cost one other
points
okay it's gonna be like a unique unique
nearest neighbor
okay so what would this point again you
take this query point and and you also
perturb it by a Gaussian so what you
really get a query still that but this
is not very important
the difference here is not I mean when
you go to the math it's not that
important the question is how close is Q
to the to the tool data point at the
closed one so there is a pistol there is
a one a point P star which is the
closest one which is within distance one
that's like the right nearest neighbor
and we're gonna assume that for
everybody else
the distance is 1 plus at least one plus
Epsilon if there's no tilde then it
should be its I try to be very
consistent I hope I didn't make a
mistake but okay then you put to
everything you took the points P and you
put up Q right but like the initial
question okay that's a good question so
it depends on the amount of noise I said
the noise is huge but it's huge you've
seen a minute but it's still so so that
the exactly stable remains the same okay
this requires calculation that may
depending on how large it is this is
pretty large so I'm going to talk about
the dependence mostly on teeth okay so
this Sigma right this is like the
Gaussian standard deviation every
direction I really like 1 over D to the
1/4 you'll see in a minute why I'm gonna
ignore depends on epsilon K and log n ok
they're also like you have to be like
smaller by something like K log n +
epsilon a 1 over Epsilon so I'm gonna
ignore these terms ok so think of it
this way
okay so
yeah okay so what happens they know he's
large what is the magnitude of the noise
well it's a basically a Sigma in every
direction
to sum up its going to see what x
squared it as the magnitude of the
perturbation and by my choice is about
Dietl 1/4 which is bigger than 1 okay
much bigger and pick up like epsilon
maybe is like point 1 and never all
these are like small constants kind of
and but this is large ok so the noise
the amount of perturbation actually move
is much bigger than the initial distance
you start with 1 okay however you can
still put that exact nearest neighbor
which is the same in this case it
happens because Catholic although the
perturbations are very close to the
expected perturbation
highly-concentrated
and that's kind of like the deviation in
this distance and they're all going in
which direction well kind of called
shogunate to the k space k dimensional
space alright so they all grow like
contribute the same for all the points
and so on so they got to be the same
amount and that's that's what answers
your question so what happened is model
because there are so much noise the top
K dimensions of this people like you
tried to do SVD and you look the top K
subspace right obese PCA of whispah
tilde it's going to get the aggregate
sub constant mass because just the noise
is so large
basically it affects the top K sub space
and and therefore like older I should
look almost the same or something and
it's as opposed to having like in P well
if you start with P without the
gaussians then you have like k+ similar
values and then don't get 0 so this
would not work and Johnson answer will
not work either because after the
perturbation the businesses are still
the closed one the the one that you
start P star is still the closest one
but the gap is narrowed by so much right
I mean both the closest and then not the
second closest points in the same order
but the values are now very close to
camera you edit like a huge quantity to
both them I put two this one will be
like 1 plus this this nice right in both
them and one we delete the second one's
gonna be plus some Epsilon
so it's going to be
very indistinguishable photos of
themselves kind of projections okay so
what the algorithm would you like to do
you still gonna use want to use PCA so
how do you find when I find these
subspace unknown subs with you okay of
course the natural thing is I try to
compute the topcase subspace you and
solve the enemy nearest neighbor search
probably right because if you go to the
top K subspace
intuitively you're going to get you want
to get this subspace you as your
solution you project all the points to
there because you want to cancel out the
noise and then once you're inside K
dimensional subspace you can do the
computation quick because quickly
because K is small so this would be done
if we sub if this PCA exactly recovered
so I'm going to use the letter s for
this algo de algodón God gives us which
is the subspace top K dimensional
subspace s ideally ideally it's gonna be
you but because of the no you stop it's
not gonna be exactly if it were you
wouldn't be done this is opposed
okay so is it true that we can do some
such a thing like somehow reduce the
problem to a k-dimensional sauce let's
get rid of the noise and then use
whatever algorithm is known for K
dimensions this is basically the best we
can hope for with this model because we
started with a worst case k dimensional
scenario right in this case I mention
this subspace to you I didn't put any
assumptions the point need not be
uniformly distributed on this this space
subspace you
so that's the best we can hope for and
effect you want to reduce the dimension
D okay and the spoiler fall can you see
the answer is yes we can do this okay so
we're not gonna as I said we're not
going to find exactly you that's gonna
be a problem the problem is that out of
these K important directions in this
subspace you this unknown source is you
let's think of it like maybe half of
them are really stormed and have a
really weak
okay like I don't know endpoints going
like this use this K over two directions
and squared endpoints use another cable
two directions uniformly or whatever
squirrel ten points are going to give
you much less contribution to this SVD
than the endpoints not a list basically
endpoints so you're not going to see
them and then they're gonna be overtaken
by the noise then no he's gonna give
something already bigger so here is like
an illustration suppose these are like
the two important directions One
Direction really a lot of points go in
that direction and there's one point
there like in the second direction now
if you try to project on you know you're
not going to see this either the second
directly this is case k k equals two
alright so you want the algorithm you
this you find this direction but the
second direction that you find is some
random direction so you basically don't
see this and you're gonna project on
listen and now everything cause it's
gonna be a like a mess because you're
gonna get to use results just because
they being collect on half the
directions in intuitively it's not
enough been caught on all K directions
that's at the point you okay so here is
the intuition for the first argument we
do well the algorithm is going to be
effective but not for all the points
it's only going to be effective for a
subset of the points it's gonna be a
large subset that's good we're gonna
make a lot of progress and we have to
identify which subset of the points we
can do it's gonna succeed on so we're
gonna call this like well captured
points so which are which points are
called
it is like intuitively the moment which
points are well captured points where
the signal is mostly inside the the top
is a space of the algorithm that should
be okay so if s is close to you then I
think that for many points this the what
I'm going to find so in this algorithm
and in this example sorry if we run the
algorithm when we find two direction
which is this one in some random
direction in space then all these points
will look at the like the right place
but this one looks like unrelated so you
want to can ignore this point we can
identify this right because in our
computation these points lie in this
case inside the space
and that outlier lies outside the space
s that we find okay and the idea one
more thing about the high level once we
do that if we can manage to let's say
sort of half the points here then we're
good we're going to prepare a data
structure for them remove them from the
data set now we have like another n over
two points for which we don't know
whether we have a good algorithm we can
just run the same algorithm recursively
on n over two points and continuous
that's gonna be like log in different
data structures and then we do just
iteratively ok so here's a more
precisely what is the first algodón
which is relatively simple you find the
top pca this is like the pre-processing
right you find top is a subspace s you
find in the set C which is all the
points that are really captured well by
this substance which your definition I'm
gonna give you in a minute and then you
build the near neighbor search data
structure only on this set C ok so
that's let's say think we like half the
points of something oh and you take the
set C but you project it on the subspace
s because basically you want to cancel
the noise ok now let's suppose you have
a data structure on on n over two of the
points what's gonna happen with the
other n over two well just take this out
they're gonna have to repeat recursively
build a new data structure for them
again over four and so on so I'm gonna
have eventually if this works like this
log in data structures for sizes and n
over two and over four and so on so the
overall size is fine when I have a query
I'm just gonna run it against each of
these data structure so can be log n
kind of like queries that's a slow
learner to factor or logon in the
runtime and the space is fine everything
is fine okay so it's enough to analyze
basically one iteration any sense yeah
yes completely ignoring the issue of
noise it's all your fair labor I
completely ignore the issue of accuracy
of prediction it's only about the
runtime of the near neighbor search yeah
they stay the same thing I don't talk
about the accuracy of the labor but so
yeah sorry so I wanna make sure that
this works and the issue is that that
this set s that we find is not really
you it's only close to you in some
limited way like I said before like
twin-tuition thing go like careless to
of the direction that it finds they're
really coming from you and cover it or
just like condom coming from the noise
okay so you have to figure out which are
these cable to and also what has me to
be closed okay so okay so they start
with like a simpler model well they know
is actually smaller but then if it's so
small and it can be adversarial okay so
it's worth being something like
perturbation which is very large here
the perturbation I'm assuming it's like
epsilon which is right so it's like
smaller than point one where the tool
distance is about one so the
perturbation can move the point right P
tilde better speak up to this alpha
alpha I which is the small but in
arbitrary direction
okay so then I'm gonna say that the
point is called well captured okay so I
look at all the data comes all the B's
people that are having the algorithm and
I compare them to the PC a space that I
got so if it's close if it's within
distance to alpha alright because just
like in the picture I had before the
points are on this exactly on inside the
space or very close to the space say oh
my space s that I found really spans
that direction is good and for some
point maybe I didn't find the right
direction so I'm not gonna expand its
gonna be like very far from space okay
so this is definition the point that is
close to what they algorithm finds so I
can I can do in the pre-processing time
when I build the data structure I can
actually compute this and see which
points are well captured which points
are not another two lemmas to say first
if the point is well captured then the
near neighbor such this this iteration
will actually find it if the query is if
this is the optimal point we star then
this iteration of the nearest neighbor
search will actually find this point
okay let's just by triangle inequality
here because everything is moved a
little bit and like move that Kevin I
meant by moving the point back into the
subspace s it was perturbed but then I
move it back but instead of into you I
move it back into s that's that the time
getting cold
that you see okay so you look what
happens it s in s it's very similar to
what happened in you and I knew
everything was fine
so up to be small arrows which are
smaller than epsilon this is fun and
enters there the second argument is that
the number of iterations local it make
this really to tell you needs to show
that really you the number of well
captured points is like half of
something or so of the points okay this
happens because if you look at this
total signal that you have because every
point is unit length then like the four
vinius normal total sum of squared
length is something like like n and
therefore something it cannot be that
all the points give you a very little
very little signal okay this is a
reasoning precise calculation but yeah
actually but that's the yeah to find
them not oh you mean like after we find
all of them you to build them into one
data structure this I think is going to
be difficult this thing is going to be
difficult because it could be that as I
said that trigger like end the end
points use about half of the directions
care about two directions and then the
good endpoints use another half two
directions so totally you have like K
direction or the entire signal is in k
dimensional space but really most of the
signal comes from K over two dimensions
right they come to put a lot the other
ones can be like what end compared to
anything it's I mean the total and it's
like overshadowed by the noise which is
like large per point because all the
other points noise so really they know
is gonna be so large that is fruit and
point just like not enough I can
advertise economy like very little
signal in that in that direction that
you you're looking for if what you're
gonna do he'll basically if you follow
this recipe you basically move all these
end points the first end points now
you're looking only this road end point
that remain all of a sudden you have
like this a very clear signal where
they're going compared to the noise in
them right because now now you don't
have the other points so you have the
signal in this point and then noise in
these points now it's comparable you
know saying initially you have a there
is no time from end points and that's
too large this secondary signal maybe
you could wait the points if you wait
when the points appropriately the square
root n points would be more weight and
maybe you could so to make it was yeah
you could try to do like maybe I mean I
have not thought about like something
like multiplicative weights and then
still take you like lock-in iterations
and I still don't see what the advantage
versus be moving them because
effectively it's like smooth like like
so removal I mean might have added
benefits but just for this I might get
you away from these very strict
assumptions all right so so now I'm
gonna move to dig what I said is like
well the the noise is really condom so
and then it's large okay but then we
have to use the fact that this noise is
really random it's like highly
concentrated oh oh it has like average
averaging properties because you have a
lot of perturbations not for just for
one vector for one point so we're gonna
use this here is like that the basic
argument in like few lines think of it I
guess the matrix right of columns are
the data points so you have the PT by P
plus GS we said Jesus just the matrix of
gaussians what can you say about the the
singular values well if you look just on
G then you have a bound on the singular
values which is well-known for
undramatic theory alright so each era
remember i mean lambda is like the
maximum singular maximum singular value
because Sigma is the standard deviation
of the the perturbation okay so so you
can burn them it by something like n of
a hope D okay for the singular values on
the other hand if you look at P then the
rank is K you all right an h1 has
direction at least one a magnitude at
least one
okay so you get some that at least one
direction or should be at least n over K
because a total the for business number
some squared length at least n and this
corresponds with some of squared
singular values alright so so here if
it's a fist n and I only kill non
nonzero singular values at least one
singular value must go to be like n over
K in one smooth squirrel
okay maybe all of them maybe only one of
them that's exactly the issue that you
don't know not really it could be that
only one of them is like that large it
could be the torque a of them either
even is spend or not this exactly this
is exactly the point where it shows how
important they are in the singular
values I mean this it shows in the
analysis because that's for the the
hidden point it but that's very very
important quantity so basically what's
going to say well we're going to look
only the directions that passed this
thing with is a threshold you put it
like 1 over 10 times this and this is
the threshold we're not going to look at
direction that passed this threshold and
if you know things that are smaller ok
this special is high enough that the
random Direction will not so when you
sum up these things that the singular
values can adapt or cancel I mean can
adapt with positive and negative signs
so the large direction will remain large
but it can be not affected too much by
this quantity because this is small is
like where we set the parameters and
those that are small I cannot say
anything about them because it's only
few of them maybe only few of the mallet
Eastern over K there ones a lot smaller
than the threshold I'm not going to
handle them now they're going to be
handled by the next iterations basically
okay so now there's the other technical
aspect that we need to deal with is what
does mean for subspace s to be close
with a subspace you and actually okay I
think I didn't say it explicitly the
subspace s that we're going to choose in
the algorithm is really only the PCIe
directions or singular values that
passed this threshold so of course it
can be at most care of them because they
sum up to again but I don't know a
priori what number it's basically based
on a threshold not based on up we're
choosing K top directions okay so now
I'm gonna choose compare this SMU you we
said as dimension K s what algorithm
computes dimension at most K so how do
you compare these things these are the
top single average well known that it's
not really stable at the perturbations
because you have like the top say eigen
vector there's a tie between two values
one per tube one of them is going to be
larger and whichever you guess to be the
right one
you'll be very fond but it is stable if
the second singular value is separated
is much smaller than the first one and
it's going to happen in this case not
for the first in a second but because
this noise magnitude is much smaller so
we still have to define what I mean so
we have some sort of stability
approximate some stability but I wanted
me to be close and they were going to
use a theorem that is called the
weddings sine theta children okay so
this was studied and it's basically this
quality I have a picture here so you see
men okay it's a measure of proximity
between the subspaces as a new in this
case it's called teto of sine theta of
this thing there's this quality and let
me tell you what it is in my picture
okay you have a subspace you and now you
your algorithm compute this subspace s
is s close to you
okay take any point in s the worst point
the maximum point that's here right and
you see what's the closest point in you
and if there is somebody in you is
closed that means that s is close to you
so in this case s could be a smaller
dimensional subspace and you of course
if it's bigger than somebody who can be
far away it doesn't make sense but if
it's smaller dimension that's fine and
if it means that it that it takes some
subset of direction think of it this way
let's start with you you take a subset
of these directions you move it only by
some epsilon and this thing
this quality is gonna be bounded by
Epsilon alright so this is the way we
measure things and it's not symmetric
right because of this definition
it's from s to U or not the other way
around okay this few mm all this was
developed by Davis and Kahn and then by
waiting I think there is a can was for
symmetric matrices and weddings theorems
for general mattresses so it shows
something like this if you start with a
matrix like just like this perturbation
Theory the matrix P and then you put a
two-bit alright you take P then you put
to you get P tilde the question is if
you look at the top subspace of P and
top size of P tilde are they close it's
a small perturbation issue they should
be close so they actually develop this
to say in what sense are they close at
these definitions like I derive
definition to measure the proximity and
they also give bounds like with high
probability I guess this missing here
and I don't have to be at the same
cardinality the subspaces and so on and
it largely depends on the operator norm
of off G of the gaussians okay actually
doesn't to be Gaussian any matrix
suppose of its Gaussian then you know
that this operator norm is small okay so
this bounds like the what happens to
this evaluate the vector S is gonna be
in this particular way particular says
it's close to you okay so this is good
enough because if you remember what I
said well captured was really about
distances feel close to you if the point
was close to you what's something that's
really about the right thing which I
don't have time to go into the details
but it's really captures the right
thickness distances between I seen you
that has to be verified and didn't show
it here here like to my no but important
issues to complete the analysis one is
if you do it iteratively okay the first
iteration we said this this model and
stuff like that just like in Sancho he
talked the second iteration now the data
is not random it's affected by the
choices of the first iteration and so on
how do you analyze those that's now it's
like a mess to analyze here is like a
simple fix
instead of computing the PCI as I said
you pick something like log endpoints
okay log n points so if you have like
log n per direction
and you complete a piece a for these
points it's gonna be a very well you
have to prove that it's a good
approximation for the PC of the original
take the set so now for this point you
can't use them anymore so you can just
compare the query against them like
naively that's the only login points
that's fine and then now the next
iteration does not depend on what your
choice is in the first iteration okay
now this may be it does not need it we
don't know how to remove this from the
analysis but maybe you want to use it
anyway I mean in practice which we
didn't try I haven't seen people
reporting that they did this maybe they
do it for speed up though okay so
eventually what we can pull about this
model is that the number of iterations
is something like squared d log n and in
each one we have this subspace S which
has dimension at most K so we're gonna
run a little whatever your favorite
algorithm for K dimensions and that's
why you get this last time which is
something like 1 over epsilon to the K
and these dependencies on on on login
okay so basically we'll use it to a few
instances of K dimensional near neighbor
search okay so the second algorithm and
this is are going to be like this very
vague and very short of details it's
another algorithm will be analyzing the
same paper this is even closer to the
algorithms using parties that we
suggested is not really the kind of
thing people use in practice we use this
idea of using the PCIe directions but
it's you know some of you came up with
based on this this is similar to the
argument people have used in it's called
PCA tree and this is basically like in
this picture you find the top one even
though even though you know if think
like this K dimensional spaces you find
one the top direction the PCA direction
you project up to that direction now you
partition the point into slabs
all right so after if you have after you
project around a line basic cut it into
intervals or we think in the original
space like slabs okay so now that points
up partitioned into these sets okay and
then you repeat recursively on each
subset
the customer you do this top PCI
direction and so on okay that's the
algorithm
okay but except that when you search you
search only the right slab you also
still say then next the preceding and
successive slabs okay so you have some
in the search you actually spend a
little bit more time when you expand
this thing okay so this is the algorithm
we are actually able to analyze it and
it gives like nice results in this model
right for this no adversary plus no
published noise model it actually works
very well with all these with certain
careful analysis some point that you
have to worry about is that you have to
Center the points because after you move
the points on the slab they're gonna be
like far away in some slab so I can
flick shifted you only can flick Central
and back to the origin so that kinda
like the noises like goes in all
directions equally so that's the
technical issue and another technical
issue is that the points may accumulate
in some parts of the tree because we
started with adversarial data set you
have to be concerned that that about
these these things otherwise it doesn't
work so this is kind of like
modifications to the algorithm and I
said I will start with the Algona people
use in practice at least PCs you have to
modify it accordingly
this is centering for example okay so
overall what happened is that if you do
this three kind of PCA three the number
of iterations or the depth of the tree
is only 2k because that's that affects
the runtime and everything in 2k is like
the device dimension and then you stop
okay and then you look at all the points
at you which though so so basically the
performance of this algorithm is like
analogues to what happens in a dimension
dimension Cale okay okay so it's really
didn't reduce it to a K dimension you
restore a kind of like a kale okay
dimension problem in terms of those one
time this is because you K to the K
itself let only episode one of the lapse
into the King okay so we managed to to
do this kind of dimension reduction
about just Felice setting not general
dimension reduction let me just point
out that after least walk there's some
other algorithms that look at data aware
analysis so we look depend on the data
points in this case it's for worst case
algorithms
two three papers by Antoni resistant
hmm and a few others and kodos I mean
this is one of the paper a tight result
and here we didn't look at was this we
looked at low dimensional plus noise
okay and we showed that it actually
using PCA is really effective on these
kind of models so hopefully it can
explain when to use it or wire effective
is it effective and I think in general
that's a good question I to explain
somehow empirical success in the sense
that next time if you well if I won it
well possibly somebody else it's more
likely wanted to actually execute an
algorithm know how which algorithm to
choose for the day today
why doesn't work we first to cluster the
points and I no question Eden directive
nearest neighbor balls from the and then
replace each ball with the average and
then do pc and ax so by taking the
average of using the Gaussian noise and
by replaced and by make sure that the
different averages capture different
parts of the space so you know I've not
thought about it I think initially I
wanted to understand where would when PC
I would walk so right it's not good time
crazy no just say like legs are gonna
fall for this moment okay I mean what it
becomes easy if you find exactly if you
find the proximity then you have to get
a boundary discussed with weddings as
sine-theta theorem so the questions like
also issue of accuracy and you find like
a subspace from lower dimension you have
to find the right dimension we had
missed threshold you find the right
dimension of this effective so it's not
that's it but but going back to the
first sentence I think the cluster will
not work very well because they didn't
know it is so large
bizzy's a string first if you look at
the allergy of everything right if you
take average of points that are on the
subspace in each one had an independent
Gaussian then the sum is also on the
subspace with a Gaussian with the
smaller
okay so let's suppose I take the onion
update data set and it's symmetric for
every point P you have minus P so in
that sense I think the casting will not
work well because they didn't know is
much bigger than this signal which is
one unit and I know it's like D to the
1/4 is much bigger than say not if you
know the right direction if you put if
you know the right direction you look
only in this direction then I love small
because it's only Sigma but if you look
if you don't know what is the right
direction look just like luck in JL
right you look at all directions then it
looks like Sigma times will be which is
like the cluster is let's suppose it's
done by Euclidean distances like
proximity sum of Euclidean or sum of
squares or something like this then this
linear assumption is going to be hidden
by the nodes because you know you'll be
good if you know the subspace no but you
just partition it into balls right cover
the data set by balls of equal radius
now that's what I understood the
clustering to be now not sum of squares
or anything like that yeah you don't
even remove nearest neighbor book
because he said that the nearest
neighbors are preserved by
it's very interesting is that the
gapping 1 + + 1 plus epsilon is gonna be
like D to the 1/4 and it the 1/4 plus
Epsilon so it's additive you add to the
same quantity to both distances let me
stop being one in one perception
launches are called multiplicative Lee
distinguishable you had a huge quantity
so now they have the same older one is
bigger than the other but they almost
like the same same quantity but I have
not told about this algorithm so so
perhaps one of your questions - but can
you move further deterministic
conditioned on the noise like the
operator norm being bonded under which
this algorithm works thinking principle
as you saw in the slides now the
question is you know how much things are
I've been using in the poof I think that
should be enough however the algorithm
works in iterations so the second
iteration works on a subset of size
let's say n over 2 now it depends on the
only the same assumption on the and
that's it right so so it's not going to
be that simple but maybe you can define
it in any sense like that allow natural
to define a tree of this arbitrary
subset of size n over 2 n over 4 so on